o pianista é de leiria mas prefeito que
harry pires
partindo da idéia porque a compreensão é
chave do gosto vai falar de música
clássica
gostaria de rever seus conceitos vamos
ouvir joão costa fará o corte
existe um preconceito que a música
clássica buzina mas será mesmo a música
clássica têm mesmo de ser aborrecida
eu acredito que na música clássica assim
como em tudo o resto é aliás a
compreensão é a chave do gosto 10
minutos
vou tentar transformar a nossa forma de
ouvir danos alguns utensílios para que
possam ficar mais próximos da música
clássica
começamos como por uma pequena reflexão
porque razão existem músicas que
facilmente entre os nossos vídeos dos
dois exemplos primeiro ano à tona de
chupar
o clero de lula e de si
por que razão as duas músicas todos os
nossos ouvidos e por que razão aquelas
parece ser tão fácil de ouvir haverá um
certamente razões relacionadas com a
composição em si com organização do rico
e dos sons
a escolha dos 23 membros das dinâmicas
mas eu diria que mais importante do que
isso é pensa com combina dessas músicas
essa freqüência quando não é a excessiva
acaba por criar uma familiaridade com a
música que nos permite mais facilmente
especial acho é o que acontece com estas
duas músicas que também custou caro
certamente todos vós já ouviram pelo
menos uma ou duas vezes em filmes
anúncios publicitários o vídeo jogos e é
o suficiente para terem criado uma
familiaridade com elas
por outro lado quando essa freqüência é
excessiva
acabámos por criar um hábito que não nos
permite ter a certeza de estarmos do
fato dessa música
um exemplo disso esta pequena peça de
brahms um compositor alemão do século 19
estão ver qual é a situação de o vírus
desde o berço torna mais difícil hoje
oficial a outro risos na platéia
mas a juntar a isso ao facto da música
esta ser constantemente reproduzida por
brinquedos em qualquer possibilidade de
também não ajuda
a conclusão a tirar daqui é que parece
gostar de música clássica é importante
criar se uma familiaridade com ela
ouvindo muita música clássica mas
procurando sempre diversificar e nunca
ouviram a mesma música
a familiaridade é importante mas mais
importante do que isso eu diria que é a
compreensão
proponho vos agora que eu sou um cheiro
de uma obra bastante desconhecida
ó
pra que eu acho que não viram pela
primeira vez provavelmente 70 um pouco
perdidos como se na data num mar gigante
de sons conex nos minutos que nos restam
deixem nos ajuda a ouvir esta música
através de uma breve análise
interpretativa da obra
mas atenção não existe apenas uma
interpretação possível várias
interpretações podem ser feita a obra
chama sapucaí lectivo de dom
depois de uma leitura de data durante
cerca de um quarto nome e foi composta
no século 19 o tupi nesta húngaro pista
depois ter lido a divina comédia de
dante poeta italiano da idade média
o compositor lista escreveu esta obra
inspirada na viagem do poeta através do
inferno passando purgatório até o
paraíso
vamos ver de que forma é que eles
representa o inferno na sua música
começa a perder os sons se encontra a
uma distância bastante particular esta
distância o tribunal notas
damos o nome de trânsito no uso deste
trio paulo não é por acaso
na idade média este intervalo evitada
devido à sua agressividade
mais tarde o intervalo foi apelidade
diabolos na música o diabo na música
a referência é que ao inferno é por isso
evidente pelo uso do intervalo do diabo
a juntar a isso a outra questão é que o
lixo é própria de shiva ao inferno pelo
fato de o utilizar esse intervaldo forma
repetida no sentido de ser lento isto é
dos agudos até os gravados sendo que os
graves representam as profundezas do
inferno
e aqui algo de muito muito particular em
que se sucedem nenhum som e silêncio e
de uma gruta sombria surja uma criatura
que mal conseguimos identificar para
logo ser parceiro instalar novamente o
silêncio ea perfil e torno da paz e
silêncio o que é esse lance mas afinal a
música néviton sons não só mas também a
música clássica é tão poderosa que chega
está presente no silêncio vista
apresentado uma idéia musical baseado
numa escala traumática
uma escala cromática é composta pelos
intervalos mais curtos que podemos
realizar o piano
isto é partindo de uma nota qualquer do
piano top todas as notas que aparecem no
caminho da minha mão no sentido
ascendente no sentido de ser lento nos
românticos o cromatismo está
extremamente associado ao sentimento de
dor e portanto aqui depois da descida ao
inferno
tanto enfrenta o sofrimento mas o deic
sofrimento estou à espera da minha forma
de ver a obra mas que dão nós povo e
centro de maneira diferente
outros talvez viram um desespero pela
agitação irã em fúria outros talvez
lamentação e outros talvez nem consigo
encontrar palavras para descrever é que
o que sentem por que música clássica mas
presentemente que muitas vezes as
palavras não exprimem obrigado pela
atenção